tell them to bring me my money yeah
hello Americans or should I say
subsidiaries of Ukraine I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's December
22nd 2022 I like the symmetry of that
date we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and Blaze TV uh if you have not
subscribed Uber rumble.com please go
ahead and do that and uh we're rolling
into Christmas people we are almost done
I think I mentioned at the end of the
show yesterday uh next week giving the
people off we're all gonna spend some
time with family and friends and eat
some food all the f words but we do have
some year-end content rolling in for you
we've got uh some top clips of the Year
some of my favorite moments some viral
moments and a whole bunch more but we're
not going to just bludgeonio with
everyday stuff hopefully you can get off
the machines a little bit yourself and
uh and enjoy the season uh today's theme
is going to be about some of the top
leaders of 2022 and by top I mean bottom
because these people have not done done
a great job when it comes to doing right
by the people that they are supposed to
be taken care of or governing or
whatever phrase you want to use they
mostly have done awful things I think
this was the year of awful leaders being
exposed we had 20 20 in 2021 of awful
leaders doing awful things 2022 is the
year that that they all got exposed for
the nonsense and their morally
questionable activities their continued
lives and sort of how the whole machine
is set up to make you think you're crazy
but you're not crazy because you watch
the Reuben report so that's where we're
at today and we're going to of course
end it with a little bit of hey there's
a way off this crazy machine I I think
we can do it together so we're going to
do a little bit of that let's start with
uh one of my my Prime targets when it
comes to politicians that I do not like
Justin Trudeau up in Canada and Canada I
mentioned that America is now a
subsidiary of Ukraine we'll get to that
in a little bit uh Canada sometimes
seems like a subsidiary of the United
States and Justin Trudeau seems to take
all of the worst ideas that are exported
out of California and import them into
Canada Canada has no Mass Gun problem
Canada has no Mass racism problem uh
Canada has no Mass uh problems actually
well they have a problem with Justin
Trudeau that would be the main problem
they don't have major systemic problems
but Justin Trudeau is all about
silencing dissent he is all about taking
away guns he is all about making sure
that half the country thinks that
they're racist people who should have
their bank accounts Frozen and just
yesterday he continued on his quest to
take away guns from Canadians we will
play you this clip but again this is to
the backdrop that Canada does not have a
gun violence problem
with Justin Trudeau admitting that some
of those rifles even those used legally
by hunters will be banned there are some
guns yes that we are going to have to
take away from people who were using
them to hunt and say but we're going to
also make sure that you're able to buy
other guns from a long list of of guns
that are accepted we're going to have to
take away the guns that some people use
the what does he hunt like oh my God
yeah I love you yeah oh my god
um
look once they start taking the guns a
whole bunch of bad stuff happens okay
there are very very few mass shootings
in Canada there is very there's actually
not a lot of crime in Canada in general
certainly gun crime the idea that the
government we have to do it we us with
all the weapons and the guns and the
police and the Army and everything else
we have to just take a little bit more
from you guys even though we are
acknowledging a lot of these guns that
we're going to take are actually used
for hunting uh and I don't know if you
know about this but Canada's got a lot
of space up there there's a lot of uh
animals that are roaming around and
people do like to hunt up there you can
hunt some deer some other things the
bounties like to get up there and ride
around and find some animals
just so ridiculous we've got a little
bit more on what's going on up there
from the post-millennial a surprise last
minute amendment by the Liberals to
Trudeau's pending gun control Bill
initially pitched as a way to prevent
the sale of Canadian handguns would
result in the largest gun Prohibition in
Canadian legislative history the
National Post reports the amendment
tabled by liberal Member of Parliament
Paul Chang would criminalize a firearm
that is a rifle or a shotgun that is
capable of discharging Center fire
ammunition in a semi-automatic manner
that is designed to accept a detachable
cartridge Magazine with a capacity
greater than five cartridges of the type
for which the firearm was originally
designed so you know when we were
putting the show together this morning
and I was reading through these quotes I
will do a couple shows we'll do
something early in the year just
generally going through some of the
language related to guns magazines and
semi automatic and all that stuff
because we can talk about this stuff and
I've done a bit of it in the past but I
am certainly not going to sit here and
pretend that I am a total gun expert a
firearm expert but all of these things
you know what this is about like they
can pick okay we're going to get rid of
the okay five magazines this and okay
we're going to make sure they don't have
that what it really is about is what
happened in Canada this year that Justin
Trudeau fears more than anything else is
that the good people of Canada who had
had it with everything that he had done
to the country although they did
re-elect him although I think you know
it's roughly around 35 percent of the
vote something like that is what he
ended up with
um
they've had it with him and they've had
it with the Draconian lockdowns and they
protested him and when they protested
him and when the world was watching he
was freezing their bank accounts he was
arresting pastors at churches he was one
of the worst he would be I would say in
terms of a world leader I would put him
on par with the prime minister of New
Zealand who's like a genuine sociopath
that woman uh but uh this is what Justin
Trudeau has done and it's obvious that
it was going to go in this direction and
I would just say to my Canadian friends
uh good luck to you and we are very
welcoming of you guys down here in
Florida meeting an awful lot of
Canadians everyone thinks it's just
Californians and New Yorkers moving down
here to the free state of Florida I'm
eating a lot of Canadians a lot of
Canadians who were snowbirds meaning
that they lived up somewhere in you know
Calgary and western Canada they lived up
in Toronto and Eastern Canada they would
come down to Florida for the winter but
a lot of them are staying longer now a
lot of them are trying to figure out
what their future is is Viva fry who is
obvious he's a friend of mine and a
friend of the show on all the time who
was very successful lawyer in Canada he
now lives down here in Florida Jordan
Peterson obviously he's got his place in
Toronto he's trying to figure out how to
spend more time down here plenty of
people are trying to figure out uh you
know if you if you want to be free can
you live in Canada and I think the jury
is out on that or perhaps the jury has
already made their decision and in which
case you know what the answer is but
it's not just Justin Trudeau that is
that is sort of uh authoritarian and
doing all of these crazy things that
have nothing to do with why people
elected them we've also got this this
situation with zelenski from Ukraine as
you know he came last night he spoke to
both uh the Senate and the house joint
session of Congress and it was very odd
because we're the ones giving him a lot
of money right a lot of money we've
given them about 69 billion so far it
looks like we're going to give them
another 40 billion so we're going to be
over a hundred billion dollars I don't
know do you think we could have used any
of that here in America to perhaps fix a
stop sign or a road or something like
that I don't know maybe we're doing
everything just right here so we thought
okay we'll give this guy a hundred
billion dollars sure he shut down the
opposition parties when he took over
a little bit of a shady pass there are
some Nazis in Ukraine but all right all
right I don't want to blame you the
point he comes here he doesn't even put
on a suit he wears his usual uh his
usual green shirt and uh here he is
given a talk last night and oh here he
is with Biden actually first before we
get to the Joint session of Congress
here he is with Biden uh explaining sort
of what his parameters are for peace the
chest piece is different for me as a
president just peace is no compromises
as to the sovereignty freedom and
territorial Integrity of my country
the payback for all the damages
inflicted by Russian aggression okay so
this is sort of interesting so remember
Kamala Harris Russia big Ukraine small
remember that the implication there was
that this big bad guy Russia was
attacking small good guy at Ukraine now
that's partly true right right let's
just start from the beginning here
Russia did this Russia is the country
that invaded another Sovereign Nation
now it isn't that they just did this in
the last year you may remember when
Barack Obama was President Russia went
in to Ukraine and took Crimea back they
had it a long time ago Ukraine said
we're not going to have nukes because
you guys you the United States and the
UK you're going to defend us if anything
happens and they knew if if anything
that means if Russia does something and
Barack Obama just let it happen now I
don't even know that I would have been
for us getting into a war then just
because we had signed a piece of paper
it's sort of why every country you know
peace is only worth something the piece
of paper is is really only worth what
it's written on right like a piece of
paper is a piece of paper you have to be
able to actually defend yourself you
can't sign a piece of paper give away
your weapons and then go uh guys guys we
have this piece of paper here can you uh
can you blow up Russia for us so there's
a lot of sort of Amateur hour politics
going on here but what zielinski is
saying there that a just peace is no
compromise like if if you were if your
country is being destroyed as we're told
it is and I'm not I'm not denying that
there's an awful lot of bad stuff
happening in Ukraine and people are
dying and there's a refugee crisis and
all that I've mentioned to you guys how
we moved several of our we had to close
our locals office we've moved several of
our people out we have some of them in
the United States right now so I'm not
pretending that not that this is not
legit it obviously is legit and it's
serious and all of that stuff but the
idea that he comes here to say no
compromise like if we're the one funding
this thing we're the one giving him the
weapons we're the ones that were
supposed to make the guarantees in the
first place like the gall of this guy to
show up in his T-shirt stand there with
the president of the United States and
later we'll get to it in a second The
Joint session of Congress and basically
like no compromise no compromise we're
just going to keep going uh you know
Putin's got nukes that's a bit of a
problem so if Putin's just like no we're
not giving Crimea back and that might
just be where we're at right now where
Putin has just made his decision we are
not given Crimea back it's to uh the the
Strat strategic importance of it is just
too much we're just not doing and Putin
also knows if he gets a loss here
you know what happens to leaders when
they get a loss and they are you know
showing signs of weakness they most
likely end up like Gaddafi who was on
the Run for the last couple weeks of his
life and then you've all probably seen
the video some guy literally stuck a
knife up his ass and that was the end of
Muammar Gaddafi we don't have the video
on that all right
anyway uh the point is that perhaps
compromise is worth discussing right it
doesn't mean it's right it doesn't mean
that anything that Russia has done is
right but if your position as the leader
of Ukraine is we will take nothing other
than your surrender
the guys God nukes okay uh now let's do
this this video was going viral
yesterday I thought this was really uh
it's pretty quick but I think it sort of
attaches what the problem with America
is right now uh here's a video of
zelenski with Trump and a contrast to
zelenski with Biden I really hope that
you and President Putin get together and
consolve your problem that would be a
tremendous achievement it's an honor to
be by your side
defense against what is a brutal brutal
Wars
isn't that interesting Donald Trump was
telling zielinski only three years ago
hey you guys should talk this out
because everyone sort of knew this was
happening you can go back I didn't talk
about it that much on the show but we
did talk about it for for a bit before
this was happening this was like a slow
motion War everyone kept saying Russia
is going to invade Ukraine Putin's going
to invade Ukraine there are videos of
Biden being like we know he's going to
invade Ukraine so it's not like this
happened out of nowhere for years and
years and years Putin had been talking
about this and we knew it was going to
happen so Trump three years ago was like
hey you guys better talk this stuff out
maybe there's some deal to be cut maybe
there's something that can be worked out
here otherwise he's going to invade and
we're going to end up exactly where
we're at then you contrast that with the
Biden situation and Biden in essence is
like yeah you're the good guy he's the
bad guy how much money do you want where
are my shoes what time is it I have to
go to bed
here's zelinsky entering Congress last
night and they just love this guy
now remember they love them and their
whole gig is to take your money and give
it to him
once again and I'm going to have to stop
by by next year I'll stop qualifying it
all the time it is not to say Russia is
good it is not to say that his cause is
not just at some level but all of those
people that are in that room were
elected by Americans and I think that
Americans uh elected them to protect
American interests instead we've got
this former comedian actor from another
country that nobody was talking about a
year ago all the people with their
Ukrainian flags and their Twitter bios
and their Instagram accounts nobody was
talking about Ukraine these clowns could
not find Ukraine on a map if their life
depended on it and now somehow Ukraine
has become the most important place in
the entire world Ukraine where Hunter
Biden was doing some very shady deals is
it crazy to think that it has something
to do with that am I am I a complete
conspiracy theorist misinformation
disinformation specialist come on anyway
here's a bit of Lansky's speech and he
was a comedian in Ukraine so I don't
know is this funny you tell me so so
here is the front line The Tyranny which
has no lack of Cruelty again the lives
of free people
and your support is crucial not just to
stand in such fight but to get to the
turning point to win on the battlefield
we have artillery yes
thank you
we have it is it enough honestly not
really
it's not enough there's no amount that
would be enough there is literally no
number that would be enough and if your
implication is if we just give you more
artillery we give you more missiles we
give you more tanks you push Russia back
completely we get to exactly where we
were
what was it six months ago when this
thing started we already we still have a
problem already because of Crimea from
years ago but even if we do all of that
again
does that mean you have Victory if the
other guy has nukes
I just
are any of these clowns thinking about
any of this stuff clearly but he
continued to get more laughs
we already built strong Ukraine with
strong people strong Army Strong
institutions together with you we
develop strong security guarantees for
our country and for entire Europe and
the world together with you and also
together with you will put in
Place everyone who will defy freedom put
in
[Applause]
this guy should be writing for Colbert
put in you got it I mean
who's in charge
does it sound like we are in charge or
the guy who showed up wearing a
sweatshirt does he not have a suit put
on a suit I get that it's all theater
but just put on a suit a sports jacket
with some khakis and some loafers that
would be just fine but no he's got to
wear his green sweatshirt all the time
and uh Putin put in genius she could
have made a poutine joke which would
have brought us back to Canada that's a
gravy that they put on their french
fries those weirdos anyway uh Tucker
Carlson had a rather quick snippet that
I thought was pretty solid on this
course we know no one's ever addressed
the United States Congress in a
sweatshirt before but they love him much
more than they love you
like that's just true these people who
are giving your money to this guy who
are giving him standing ovations
they do love him more than they love you
that's unfortunate and by the way that's
bipartisan you know my line about how
you can't be a republican you can't be a
Democrat right you cannot be a Democrat
maybe you should be a republican maybe
you should be but they're going to fail
you too right
that's how it is that's just how it is
and we're seeing that right now that
being said there are a few Republicans
doing some nice work on this Mike Lee is
trying to stop this crazy Omnibus Bill
uh we've had Rand Paul obviously
fighting against it uh Ted Cruz like
there are a couple people Marco Rubio
they are realizing that we cannot
endlessly uh fight uh we cannot
endlessly fund this thing John Kennedy
from Louisiana I've got some video of
him in just a second and a bunch more uh
actually well let's just go right to the
John Kennedy so he is a republican from
Louisiana we've played a couple clips of
this guy's just got a great way with
words and how to he's just got like just
a perfect quip on almost everything and
one of the few sane DC politicians and
here he is talking about the Omnibus
Bill this is the 1.7 trillion dollar
bill that's sort of being attached to
this zielinski thing right because
within the 1.7 trillion is the extra 40
billion for this guy then again don't
forget the you know 68 roughly billion
that we've already given him here's John
Kennedy I've been given two choices door
number one is the current budget
proposals put together by uh Senator
McConnell Senator Schumer speaker Pelosi
uh it's about 133 percent no strike that
it's about a 33 percent increase over
pre-pandemic spending uh the three
people who put it together say it's the
best they can do
but there's a door number two door
number two is to wait
for a republican House of
Representatives and allow the the House
Republicans to put together a bill as a
starting point now you don't basically
that would substitute McCarthy for
Pelosi in terms of putting together a
budget bill you don't have to be a
a senior at Caltech to figure out if
your objective is fiscal restraint
you're better off with McCarthy than
Pelosi
we have a lot of big government
Republicans and we have a lot of
Ritz-Carlton Democrats in this Congress
and most of them don't believe that the
spending makes any difference
in terms of the America's economy and
our attempt to reduce inflation now I
don't agree with them
um
I think those who believe that
were probably in the quad playing
frisbee during econ 101 but we're going
to find out because I think this budget
that they put together is uh is going to
pass
okay so first the end yeah this thing's
gonna pass it's just gonna pass this is
how it works
they scare the hell out of everybody
they jam it through by sending it to
people at 2 A.M on a Tuesday night they
know no one's read it 4 200 pages of
this literally nobody's read it they lie
about when people got the information
they have insane amounts of pork in
there for crazy funding of insane things
including further funding of the NIH and
all of the stuff that has done all of
the bad stuff and they just keep doing
it but at the very least
what Kennedy said there is right at the
very least so so we're on the the 22nd
today is the December 22nd so about nine
days left in this year rolling into
Christmas all the Republicans would have
to do right now is demand with with
whatever power they have they could in
essence say listen we're not signing
this thing we're just not signing this
thing what we're going to do is we'll
agree to fund the government for the
rest of the year so that we have a
government over Christmas I don't know
what the government's doing but okay
let's have a government over Christmas
honestly the biggest Christmas gift to
me would be that we wouldn't have a
government that would be of absolute
pleasure I guess I've become an
anarchist here
um but what the Republicans should be
doing this is what he is saying and this
is exactly by the way what McCarthy said
yesterday because McCarthy is about to
be the leader of the house right he's
taking over for Pelosi as Kennedy said
you fund the government to the end of
the year and then now that the
Republicans are in charge it's not that
they're going to be that great they will
not be that great right you don't have
to be a republican but you cannot be a
Democrat that's what I always say they
will not be that great they will fail
you blah blah blah but fun the thing to
the end of the year then when
Republicans take over then how about we
rewrite a more sensible bill and we cut
some of the pork and maybe I don't know
could uh you think zelenski would be
okay if we gave him say I don't know 30
instead of 38 billion you think he'd be
okay could we get some receipts on any
of this stuff but of course they're not
going to do it the thing's gonna pass
and it'll cause inflation to go up we
will exacerbate the war
etc
etc this isn't very uh Christmas Cherry
we're gonna have to we're going to
figure this thing out by the end of the
show but they keep lying to you guys
they keep censoring you we know the FBI
is working with Twitter literally paying
Twitter to watch what you're saying and
all of this stuff so here is our black
lesbian press secretary Karin
Jean-Pierre uh referring uh well she's
talking about
what's going on with the FBI and the
hunter Biden story and oh she's just go
the latest Twitter files show that the
intelligence Community was actively
involved in discrediting the
hunter-bited laptop story does it bother
the president and those at the White
House that a government agency like the
FBI was involved in suppressing a
legitimate news story again I'm just
going to refer you to the FBI I'm not
going to comment from here about that
it's so wild she's so as I said
yesterday there's no one in the history
of the world that could be worse at
their job than she is at her job she's
so transparently dishonest the question
was how does Biden feel about it how
does the administration feel now knowing
that the FBI was in cahoots with big
Tech to take out the hunter Biden story
The the question was not did you guys
have anything to do with it why could
she not say very clearly
um we don't really like the idea of our
agencies working with private companies
to silence Americans and quash stories
that are of importance to the average
American right why don't why couldn't
she say that well the obvious answer to
that is she's thrilled about it right
this is what the swamp is the Democrats
more than the Republicans but the
Republicans too the Democrats and big
Tech and these agencies they work to
silence information you don't know
exactly what the truth is as I always
say the truth is now A Time release pill
so usually a year or two later you
actually get to the truth and a whole
bunch of people who are wrong about
everything pretend that they were there
the entire time and then it causes the
people who are right about most of the
stuff to really start getting annoyed at
everybody else because it's like come on
guys like get on the get on the ship
here already like get on board come on
come on but they keep lying they keep
censoring uh but there is an out there
is an out which I think will get us to
the uh Christmas spirit portion of this
the out is
that people are waking up right like you
watching this right now do you feel a
little more awake as opposed to woke
right now like after everything we found
out in the last couple weeks with the
Twitter leaks and and you know the 51
this is what they were referencing there
the 51 intelligence officials who
claimed that the hunter Biden laptop was
Russian disinformation that it all
turned out to be true or when you look
back uh on that video that interview we
showed you from you know what's it two
years ago now it's probably a little
over two years ago where Donald Trump
was on 60 Minutes saying that the hunter
Biden laptop is real and uh the
correspondent's like no no no we can't
authenticate it or all of the things
related to covid and everything else
that there were some of us that did not
lose our mind
that stayed roughly sane and I I still
think it and maybe it's a little
pollyannaish maybe it's a little
rose-colored glasses kind of thing but I
still think there are more of us than
them and I also think for some reason
for some reason the truth does win in
the end I don't know why I think the
truth somehow this would be a sort of
Jordan Peterson version of it like the
truth is so fundamentally tied to
reality
that like the structure of reality that
the truth these people who lie about
everything and who make you think while
they're doing all the bad stuff they
make you look there and they make you
think that the good guys are bad guys
and the bad guys are good guys they
can't hold that forever and I think
that's why we're seeing so many things
collapse in real time right now so the
the the silver lining
is that the world's richest man got
involved in this thing and gave us a
little nugget a little nugget now what
you do with that related to your voting
habits or your lifestyle habits or where
you live
or what non-profits you donate to at the
end of the year or whatever what schools
you send your kids to that's up to you
but I really do think the Silver Lining
is there is some sanity out there let's
put it this way had we not found out
what we've now found out through the
Twitter leaks that the government for
sure was working with social media
companies to censor us which again you
knew right I knew it was like you don't
have to show me a piece of paper with it
to tell me what time it is like I know
you can tell there's a sun up there you
can estimate you can guesstimate
we can we can wake up more people I
really believe it and that that's our
job so imagine had Elon Musk not bought
Twitter and none of this stuff leaked
out well the screws would have been
turned more against us it would be sort
of like you know this was this is what
it reminds me of and this is why I
couldn't vote for Hillary when I went
into the The Ballot Box uh in 2015 to
vote in November of 2015.
and I did not know who I was going to
vote for I hated Hillary there was some
stuff I liked about Trump but I thought
the personality was off I did not know
what to do and I was like I just can't
vote for Hillary I ended up that in as
you guys may remember in 2016 I ended up
voting for The libertarian Gary Johnson
libertarian candidate Gary Johnson who
was really not a great libertarian nice
enough guy I'd like to go skiing with
him sometime but like nothing was really
there but my feeling on not voting for
Hillary more than anything else was that
if you vote for Hillary then all the
stuff that we can kind of see that's
wrong with everything you just tighten
those screws against us it's just more
of that and Trump and a lot of people
saw this I suppose before I saw it they
saw the other thing which was Trump may
be messy and crazy but he's the one
that's loosening the screws of the
machine
so now you take this to all these years
later and it's like look where we are
after covid after this Ukraine situation
after the censorship and everything else
it's like there's a lot of forces that
are you know tightening those screws
against us but then Elon Musk comes in
and unscrews some of those things and
then look how the system treats him and
also you know the FBI by the way uh
released the statement yesterday
basically saying that uh you know we've
always done this sort of stuff meaning
collusion with big tech people have
known it and the people who are talking
about it are a bunch of misinformation
Specialists and conspiracy theorists and
it's like
uh I don't think did you guys know that
that the government openly works with
tech companies and other companies to
silence people I did not know that for
sure I didn't see the paper on that one
I mean again I suspected it like we all
kind of knew it but we didn't know it in
a hard concrete way uh what they should
have done the FBI actually is said hey
you know what this information is leaked
out uh it is true we've been doing this
for a while we do understand the
concerns that some some of you may have
as Citizens in the United States that
you're worried about civil liberties and
you're worried about the First Amendment
and the Bill of Rights and the
Constitution all that stuff and we'll
try to be more transparent that would
have been something but they can't they
do exactly what the media does with
everything you always double down so you
person out there who has some ballpark
estimation of what the truth is you are
a conspiracy theorist for thinking that
the government should not use your tax
dollars to fund agencies that will work
with companies to silence you
and that is all I think about that uh
let's get to some comments from the uh
oh well with all that in mind
and I'll have a little bit more for you
on this tomorrow and then next year
we're going to really unveil a lot of
this one thing connected to all of the
the big Tech stuff is uh that as you
guys know I uh I started locals a couple
years ago because I was very concerned
about what was going on with free speech
online we eventually merged with Rumble
and as we go into 2023 we're going to be
expanding on that partnership in a
couple ways tomorrow I'll tell you I'll
give you a little hint on one way that's
going to change a little bit of the
structure of the show that we're doing
here uh all in good ways like great ways
it's more stuff basically and more stuff
that will be protected from Big Tech
nonsense and you know less Reliance on
YouTube and all all of those other
things so there are people out there
that are that are building new products
that are addressing the issues honestly
and we just gotta keep running with that
that is the way out even if the
Republicans are not as bad as the
Democrats they are not the ones that are
going to save you believe it or not guys
you are going to save yourselves all
right a couple comments from Ruben
report.locals.com
zionists says Republicans have dropped
the ball on this to how easy is it to
fool so many people at one time it's so
disappointing right and what's
interesting about it is that even though
you have some Republicans who I
mentioned before Mike Lee Rand Paul Ted
Cruz Etc
who are fighting it the machine I mean
that line when when McConnell said that
line that we played for you yesterday
that that's the number one Ukraine is
the number one priority on Republicans
Minds like that's nuts that's nuts I do
a lot of stuff with politics all day
long and current events and the culture
wars I'm out there okay when I walk
around this you know I go to a store
people say hi to me they tell me what's
on their mind nobody says anything about
Ukraine can you believe Biden's got
brain damage that's up there fighting
brain damage Ukraine not up there but
they will fail you every time
and that's why I always say you don't
have to be a republican but you can't be
a Democrat the Democrats are completely
gone sold out through and through there
is not a same voice in the party the
Republicans at least have a couple
people at a national level the Senators
that I just mentioned and then at a
state level they do have a lot of good
people and obviously Florida okay fine
but it's happening in Tennessee as well
and if you haven't seen my interview
with Marcia Blackburn senator from
Tennessee that we put up a couple days
ago you should check that out it's like
there are some good things happening at
the state level with Republicans and
that's why you don't have to be a
republican you probably should be just
for Saturday's sake because we we're in
a duopoly and you want to stop the
Democrats
but yeah they will they will fail you uh
Tali says hoodoo 1984 would be a
prophetic piece yeah I mean Orwell's got
to be looking back going Mamma Mia like
you know like
this is too obvious everything new speak
the reversal of truth that everything
that the system puts out will be a lie
like the entire thing it's all there
right it's all there 1984 man if you
haven't read it lately like you
absolutely should or you can even watch
you know on YouTube they've got these
little synopsises you can watch like an
eight minute video that'll sort of give
you the full thing and it's just yeah
fiction is now reality uh weekly cigar
news says the major problem that I see
about this bill is that the Democrats
the demo Rats the demo rats are
preventing
I think I'm missing a line in there or
something I might be missing a part of
that sentence in there
um yeah I think we're missing part of
that
you're gonna copy and paste a little bit
more but yes okay I think you I think
you got the oh here we go uh the
Democrats are preventing having any say
for 18 months well look this is why okay
I got it now oh all right let me reread
the whole thing sorry this is all
happening on the fly right here can you
go down a little bit weekly cigar news
says the major problem that I see about
this bill is that the Democrats are
preventing Republicans for having any
say for 18 months look you can't only
blame the Democrats here the Republicans
as uh Joe Kennedy just laid out and as
McCarthy laid out yesterday it's like
they could do a little something to stop
this thing but they're all going to sign
the freaking thing Mitt Romney is
drooling and salivating as he gets to
sign this thing so this is what the
thing does it it funnels more money to
the people that are in the thing and it
uh it is none too kind to those of us
who offer up a little a little bit of
Truth and I would also just say that
again as I always say to Big Tech in
mainstream media and I will say it to
the politicians you guys don't have to
be great you really don't have to be
great but could you just not be
completely hard that's really the main
message to our politicians I think
that's my closing message for the year
to the politicians of America you don't
have to be that great we don't think
you'll be that great and I'm talking
about
at the federal level right because again
there are exceptions especially here in
Florida you don't have to be that great
but just don't be the worst possible
thing that we could possibly imagine you
do that would that be too much
I think it would actually
ladies and gentlemen if you have not
subscribed please do it rumble.com Ruben
report if you want to play along during
the show live chat get Advanced videos
and a whole bunch more uh
reubenreport.locals.com tomorrow is our
last show before Christmas I hope
everybody is uh thinking about what
they're going to be doing next week and
I hope you've got great plans and you're
going to be around people you love and
all that good stuff we're going to take
a little time off as I said we pre-taped
a bunch of stuff so you get a few things
next week best of and some of my
favorite moments the favorite moment
thing like it was such a whacked out
year we do our 15 favorite political
moments of the year and it's like man
this all happened in one year holy
shmoly uh anyway I'll see you tomorrow
and then we'll see you in 23 and we
leave you with the wizard known as
Kamala Harris you know I like Venn
diagrams okay so if you look I do
remember Venn diagrams those three
circles right and then let's just see
where they overlap I love Venn diagrams
okay I love vent diagrams I just love
Venn diagrams you know the three circles
right sometimes there are more I love
Venn diagrams
[Laughter]
you know the three circles he sees the
Venn diagram of it all he sees that
there are those circles and maybe people
seem that they're a little different
they live in different parts of the
country they may be different age or
different race but that area in the
middle that overlap I happen to love
Venn diagrams